-Republicans have promised
to pass their tax plan
by the end of the year,
which has Capitol Hill
scrambling.
To find out a little bit more
about how things are going
in Washington, we've come up
with a new segment called
"Just the Tax, Ma'am."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Paul Ryan continues
to push hard for tax reform,
though it's hard
to push anything when
you don't have a spine.
[ Laughter ]
-Leave em' alone!
-Excuse me?
Haven't we made fun
of Paul Ryan enough?
-Well, you know,
he is a public figure,
so I think it's okay
to make jokes about him.
-Leave em' alone.
Poor guy, day in and day out,
just trying his best.
The last thing he needs
after a long day at work
is to turn on the TV and see
you ripping him a new one.
Leave em' alone!
[ Laughter ]
-I'm sorry, are you
a Paul Ryan supporter?
-If I'm a supporter of anything,
it's compassion.
It's human decency,
not snide little jokes.
If you have to make fun
of somebody, make fun of me!
-Yeah, I don't even know you,
so why would I make fun of you?
-Well, you could make fun of
the fact that my toenails grow
so fast that I have
to clip them twice a day!
[ Laughter ]
-Not really something
you should tell people.
You know, I just usually tell
jokes about people who are
in the news,
people like Paul Ryan.
-Oh, sure,
make fun of Paul Ryan.
Have your fun.
Go ahead and say he looks
like a lipless Dracula
who just shed his skin.
-Whoa, that's really harsh, man.
-I know, so leave em' alone!
-You know, I think I would just
love to get back to my jokes.
-Oh well, you know what
you'd love, a laugh.
And how about this?
You could make fun of the fact
that I dress my dog up as Santa
and my cat up as Jesus,
and I make them fight about
the true meaning of Christmas!
[ Laughter ]
Or, you could make fun of
the fact that sometimes
I whisper things to Superman
because I figure
with his super-hearing,
he can hear me.
-I would really rather
just make fun of Paul Ryan.
-[ Whispering ] Leave em' alone.
-What?
I can't hear you.
-Well, I was talking
to Superman!
-Sir, why don't you
please sit down
so we can continue the show?
-Fine, go ahead and get back
to your Paul Ryan jokes.
You know what I'd say to that?
-I'm guessing you'd say,
"Leave em' alone."
-Leave em' alone!
If you need to make fun
of somebody, make fun of me!
Make fun of the fact
that when I got married,
I took my wife's name --
her first name!
So now my legal name
is Beverly Beverly.
-What was your name before that?
-Susan Beverly.
-Okay.
-Wow.
-Need some more material?
-No.
-Well too bad, so sad.
Leave em' alone,
because I got more.
You could make fun of the fact
that I pee a little bit
every time I cry, and I cry
a lot every time I pee!
[ Laughter ]
Or, you could make fun of
the fact that the reason the --
they announced the walkway is
about to end is because
every time I step on one
I scream, "Dear God,
when is this ending?!"
[ Light laughter ]
Or you can make fun of the fact
that my nickname is Miniballs!
But it's not what you think.
It's because I have
tiny testicles!
[ Laughter ]
Or you could make fun of the
fact that I lost my virginity
when I was 24,
and it came back when I was 31.
-Alright, that's enough.
You can just sit down, sir.
-[ Tearfully ] Fine,
I'll sit back down.
-Oh, no, I didn't mean
to upset you.
-No, I'm not upset,
I'm just peeing.
-Alright, that's enough!